yacht le monde s'excuse auto se
retrouvent sur die light par lasser
l'écran de chargement mais normalement
dans quelques secondes ça devrait être
le jeu mais on fait ça visible à l'écran
de chargement et ben voilà on a déjà un
peu plus de quoi s'amuser un peu pour
ceux qui connaissent pas des night en
fait ça mélange entre mirror's edge à
savoir 2 tu me demandes parcours
absolument voilà un petit peu comme ça
hein on regarde les politiques si on va
lire la montre on se lèche la veine et
dead island voilà donc c'est à dire que
normalement et des zombies alors pour le
moment il est absolument aucun zombies
c'est bon ça a de la gueule en des
jambes et le lancer de thomas cook
allez allez qui en veut en voici c'est
la galette des rois qui aura la faible
je me le demande a peut-être toi encore
a apparemment il s'est cassé les deux
jambes fin du jeu mais que mais qu'est
ce que c'est un tueur de zombies
viens là c'est pour toi
ah non non non non non ce que tu
voudrais que ça devait se passer
et regardez mes nouvelles chaussures
elles sont extrêmement confortables le
monde veut pas rouge peu avant d'aller
peut-être pas par là mais par contre ici
on peut vendre des fruits allez roger
tomates gratuite pour la journée est-ce
que chez d'autres armes attention au bob
le bricoleur est parmi nous il faut
savoir que c'est la démo du jeu est pas
le vrai jeu ce qui fait qu'on a un petit
compteur en bas à droite et que quand
ils arrivent à 0 il faut tout
recommencer depuis le début ah mon dieu
ceci était un guet-apens ont dit elle
nous attendait dans les fougères le mur
tu a séduit ah mais non mais non mais
attends wah wah au motif auquel le
zombie explosive c'est normal
moi je vais passer par là hop je vais
t'aider mon ami regarde regarde comme je
t'aime je suis extrêmement gentil
acheter et des deux oat les armes ou
donne moi de l'argent
oh oui voilà c'est ça voilà tu m'as
donné 200 $ à je crois que tu vas tomber
on regarde regarde bien
enfin voilà qu'est ce qu'il eût prôné
lui tient mélanie voilà un gâteau pour
te remercier ou là ou là où le mur à
faut que j'aille sur le pont mais
comment voulez vous que j'aille sur le
bon qui est tous là ou alors quoi je
suis là et qu'en plus cela ils veulent
faire une rave party
oh mathieu tu me reconnais on était
ensemble l'uncp souvient font un
et c'est pas comme ça qu'on dit bonjour
tient là dessus
oh non c'est la fin de la démo c'est un
jeu mains de mr jacquet a bien et où il
m'a pas laissé prendre possession de mon
corps attendez j'entends des cris
qu'écrite adorait les mois et c'est beau
la violence je suis désolé mais au moins
on n'aime pas de projet gré pour ce soir
les enfants en c'est lui qui écrit comme
ça non mais en fait y'a un mec dans le
placard élan politique
le mec s'est réfugié dans son placard
pour aller vite il se réfugie dans sa
machine à laver que c'était aussi
ridicule oh c'était sympa ça hein
voilà voilà maintenant tu as eu une
nette de scott dans x men qui est là je
joue
what i look at what you say voir à quoi
il va parler j'avais l'impression de
voir ça en fait ça va tu fais un
shuriken est-ce qu'il va sortir son
placard quand même nom mais qui est
traumatisé va rester là dedans en
position foetale
mais le mec qui a une épidémie de
zombies tout autour de lui le seul truc
qui trouve à faire c'est une battle de
regard on va l'appeler l'homme scarface
sport
c'est l'heure de jouer au foot qu'elles
ont bien joué au foot boîte c'est mon
but c'était bien de faire un tour sur
lui-même pour taper dans le vide alors
je sais pas pourquoi des mecs qui vont
cette tenue 1 et qui en est quitte on
voit là mais c'est la fête à 8 août toi
aussi tu veux tomber allait bien et les
suces et de zombies dans le dos ou
carrément trouve en r&d le lui regarder
le holà c'est le mec qui fait semblant
chaque fois de dormir 1 tu dors pas fait
et peut-être vraiment mort merde
apparemment un survivant a tenté de
dormir ici voilà il a tenu deux minutes
de sommeil ah oui c'est vrai qu'ils ont
leur espèce de haut aux phoques est
toujours dit que quand tu as à eau la
violence regard du renard 2 il est perdu
et là il s'est réfugié sur un oreiller
mois là comme si j'avais comme s'il
n'était pas là et qu'il allait dormir
non comment vous mais c'est de la triche
voeu pieux
voilà je vais aller dans cette usine ma
foi plein de d'amis ou de zombies bien
et que là ça j'adore ça attendez le beau
gosse
wattao je suis mort j'ai tenu cinq
secondes quoi cinq secondes en milieu
hostile
c'est le genre de mec tu lâches dans une
crèche une journée et quatre bébés l'ont
tué par balles à carlos qui me suit il
me voulait mon cartable dakar douce
alors à un vilain garçon
voilà comment on répare un coup elle
alloue 12 ans mais qu'est ce qu'il fait
là ne jetez pas demandé de la vesle pare
brise de la voiture je t'ai demandé
d'aller sur la voiture
ouattara non sans déconner il son slip
or là ils pourraient pas juste passé
comme ça à manger des chèvres des
moutons ou je sais pas du boeuf la mêlée
c'est lui moi tranquille [ __ ] est ce
que le mec qui a créé jeu était fan
était fan de sasuke wah wah wah
l'attendait mais je vais y aller au
point peut à espionner des guerriers et
ça fera toujours autant rire cette
connerie
qu'est-ce qui dispute à toi est ce qu un
zombie qui fait une crise d'épilepsie b
dans tous les jeux les gens font des
crises d'épilepsie aussi comment hop hop
regardez non non ouais tu sais tu
pensais aux basques pendant les pics
dans les fixes et par là les fixer à
gauche
les pics les ok on va se détend donc
fait avoir des spasmes c'est l'heure de
rejoindre le pont c'est bon on a réussi
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a paris si un
bonsoir à tous à terme et chaude mais
mon gars mais dupont mais vous week où
la ola attendez attendez attendez on va
arranger beaux looks de leur apprendre
la hache la hache tiens ta dentition
jeune homme à elle à elle a l'air d'être
très attendu mais j'attends mais tout
est dit carrément avait été entre un
plat et maintenant allez c'est parti et
on coupe des bûches à des bûches du
maine est-ce que je peux va ramasser son
arme oui merde il faut le mettre le feu
mais taro mais des gorges et ya moi je
te t-bag mois
l'humiliation au le t-bag devant les
zombies hall alors donc vous étiez en
train de réparer une voiture qui je
pense n'aurait de toute manière j'avais
pu marcher on repasse en mode bob rae
donc là on était le petit bob et
maintenant on passe en mode trop bob non
pas gros boobs un espèce de pervers non
non ça c'était même piège sonné c'était
mon prof de français c'est en 6e 1 1
patrick je veux qu'ils aient
l'impression de revoir tous les jours et
qu'il a parlé dans sa vie mais non mais
qu'est mais qu'est ce que tu faisais toi
tu buvaient une bière sur une bachelard
l'un très bien qu'est ce que c'est mais
détends toi ô toi aussi
voici un zombie en boîte de nuit et
voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette petite vidéo sur la démo de die in
light et autant vous dire que ce jeu a
l'air d'être une [ __ ] de bombes
en tout cas moi je les biens qui fait
j'espère que vous aussi on se retrouve
vendredi soir dans une nouvelle vidéo
chat au monde peas et à bientôt
[Musique]
c'est par le groupe